NARRATOR: Jamestown.
The first permanent English
settlement in the Americas
almost completely
disappeared from the map.
Because colonists drank
themselves to death?
[record scratch]
Well, maybe.
In May of 1607, the first
colonists landed in Jamestown.
[music playing]
In 1608, more colonists arrived,
just after a fire destroyed
much of the settlement.
[screams]
They rebuilt. And things were
finally running smoothly.
Jamestownians had plenty to eat.
Deer, turtles, sturgeon, and
an abundance of shellfish
populated the land.
And local Powhatans provided
the colony with corn
in exchange for goods.
But between 1609 and 1610,
colonists experienced
a devastating famine.
[music playing]
Historians believe the
famine, or starving time,
happened for a lot of reasons.
[music playing]
In 1609, new ships arrive
with more mouths to feed.
With some 300 hungry colonists,
but less to go around,
the Powhatans, who were also
struggling to feed themselves,
cut off trade.
[music playing]
So settlers started to take
food away from the Powhatans
by force, leaving the
Powhatans to retaliate,
laying siege to Jamestown.
[screaming]
Confined to their forts,
settlers no longer had access
to the same food they used to.
[music playing]
[bird calls]
But they were able to
catch small animals,
and even resorted to
eating their dogs,
horses, and each other.
[music playing]
So a lack of food may not
be enough to explain why
the population plummeted,
from around 300 settlers
to a mere 60.
But a lack of fresh water?
Maybe.
[water gurgling]
[music playing]
Jamestown well water was
salty, due to a nearby swamp
and the James River seeping
into the colony's aquifer.
Water that's too salty
causes dehydration,
which can cause death.
Human waste also got
into the water supply,
allowing disease
to spread rapidly.
And on top of the salty,
contaminated water
were high levels of arsenic.
Some have theorized that
the Spanish were spiking
wells with the poison
to keep England
from colonizing the Americas.
But according to
scientists, it's
more likely that the arsenic
was naturally occurring.
Either way, this toxic
cocktail may be partially
to blame for the
devastating demise
of Jamestown's population.